es geht jetzt also wieder von vorne los
mit der größten oppositionspartei
beziehungsweise fraktion bfd und hiermit
herr kauder ich muss ihnen ganz ehrlich
sagen ich weiß gar nicht ob sie jetzt
oppositions portal sind oder in der
bundesregierung sitzen das war mir jetzt
nicht so ganz klar bei ihrer rede
und apropos bürgerlichkeit es ist doch
die cdu die sich von der bürgerlichen
mitte so weit entfernt hat diesen
vorwurf müssen sie sich gefallen lassen
zur spd man merkt ihnen regelrecht sie
bewegen sich auch die fünf-prozent-hürde
zu und auch martin schulz feiern schulz
merkt man der jetzt haben übrigens gar
nicht mehr da ist schon lange sitzt er
nicht mehr da der ist bestimmt schon auf
dem weg wieder nach brüssel
bei herrn schulz merkt man dass er schon
offensichtlich lange nicht mehr mit
makro und telefonieren durfte der arme
kerl so uns frau nahles
sie haben eine sehr interessante rede
abgeliefert wo sie auch die demokratie
beschwören wie kann das also sein wie
kann es sein dass du eine waschechte
demokratien wie sie es vor zu geben zu
sein scheint dass eine mitarbeiterin aus
ihrem engeren umfeld angela da muss ich
noch mal nachgucken angela nicht merken
sondern marquardt in einer post ihr der
spd doch tatsächlich anregt dass die spd
mit der antifa zusammengehen soll gegen
den kampf gegen die afd
und gegen
das ist wirklich eine schande für die
demokratie und diesen vorwurf müssen sie
sich gefallen lassen
frau merkel ich gebe ihm recht mit aller
härte des rechtsstaates müssen wir
durchgreifen gegen den totschlag gegen
die morde die sich ja mittlerweile auf
unseren straßen abspielen wenn man in
deutschland am falschen ort zur falschen
zeit ist kann es ein ja auch erwischen
und zur rechtssicherheit und zur
rechtsstaatlichkeit muss auch dazu
gehören das josefa der mutmaßliche
hacker war nachträglich hat sich
herausgestellt dass alle seine dokumente
gefälscht waren
wir reden von dem mörder ich sage mörder
nicht tot schläger von chemnitz dass er
unerlaubt eingereiste mehrfach
straffällig geworden ist und sein
asylantrag abgelehnt wurde
das ist bei ihnen im übrigen nicht ein
einzelfall sondern es ist die regel die
sie als regierung zu verantworten haben
sie frau merkel sind zum grössten
sicherheitsrisiko in diesem land
geworden aber es geht noch weiter die
von der regierung befeuerte diese
hysterie und der unnötige
handelskonflikt mit den usa bedrohen
unsere automobilindustrie eine
gefährliche entwicklung wenn man bedenkt
welche bedeutung dieser industriezweig
in unserem land einnimmt
arbeitsplätze sind bedroht und arbeits
pendler die sich ihren diesel unter
wirtschaftlich vernünftigen aspekten
zusammen gespart haben die sind nämlich
letztlich die dummen und sie haben die
arbeitnehmer des landes und auch hier an
die stelle der spd sie haben die
arbeitnehmer des landes die unseren
wohlstand erwirtschaften und erarbeiten
längst aus den augen verloren
das zeigt auch die ewige euro retter der
merkel regierung und alle parteien
hier versuchen uns weiterhin ernsthaft
weiszumachen deutschland sei der größte
profiteur des euros und das ist nicht
wahr und das wissen sie auch wenn sie
etwas davon verstehen würden
tatsache ist nämlich die privaten
haushalte gehören zu den ärmsten in der
eurozone das legt eine vermögens studie
der ezb da die null zinspolitik der ezb
macht sie dabei von tag zu tag wärmer
das vermögen auf den sparbüchern den
pensionsfonds und der garantiezins der
lebensversicherung schmelzen dahin
während die immobilienpreise also kauf
und mietpreise durch die decke gehen so
viel zum stichwort mietpreis bremse sie
haben nämlich diese politik zu
verantworten
dazu kommt nämlich noch die von der spd
und union vier bejubelten gewinne der
deutschen exportindustrie darf der
deutsche bürger am ende ja auch selber
bezahlen das sagen sie ja nie dazu über
das tage zwei systemen nämlich muss die
deutsche bundesbank in marode
schuldenstaaten kredite gewähren ohne
eine realistische aussicht etwas von dem
geld jemals zurück zu bekommen europas
disco bei deutschland steht mittlerweile
kurz vor der billion euro marke sie
werden jetzt sagen was störe mich tage
zwei forderungen der bundesbank was
stören mich die verluste der deutschen
sparer gestern sagen sie noch herr
scholz sie wollen etwas für die kinder
tun was stört es sie dass sie genau
diese kinder und die nachfolgenden
generation um ihre vermögensbildung
bringen was soll daran eigentlich noch
soziale politik sein
die niedrigen zinsen der ezb haben dem
staat jede menge geld erspart dazu
sprudeln die steuereinnahmen alles prima
leider hat die regierung nicht nur an
den zinsausgaben gespart sie hat auch
mächtig an den investitionen in die
infrastruktur gespart es wird gnadenlos
von der substanz gelebt ist gestanden
seine zwischen folge des polit kindler
aber natürlich sehr gerne frau beide sie
haben gerade hier ein dorf erhoben
gegenüber angela marquardt den ich bei
aller schärfste zurückweisen will was
hier gemacht haben wir haben sie hier
hier im plenum diffamiert angela
marquardt hat klar gemacht die antike
auch ein vorwärts dass es notwendig ist
natürlich sich von jeder gewalt aus zu
distanzieren und gewaltfrei gegen
rassismus nazis und anziehend ist auf
die straße zu gehen
das ist gleichzeitig sehr ich muss keine
frage stelle zustimmen bemerken ist in
ordnung
es wird dazu eine zwischenfrage stimmt
mit der winter gleichzeitig es ist so
dass natürlich es wichtige
antifaschistische bündnis und
bildungsarbeit gibt gerade auch in
ostdeutschland die sehr wichtig ist bei
vielen menschen vor ort erfahren dass
sie von nazis von rassisten von
gewaltbereiten rechtsextremen
angegriffen werden
übrigens leute mit denen sie zusammen
auf die straße gehen sowie in chemnitz
und deswegen bitte ich sie hier diese
unglaublich relativierung und angriff
auf einen markt war zurückzunehmen
es ist sehr wichtig das waren
geschlossen gewaltfrei gemeindlichen
nazis und das ist auf die straße geht
das an der nordsee
[Applaus]
ich finde ihre frage sehr schön weil sie
damit eigentlich den bundesbürgern
dargelegt haben dass sie die antifa
nicht als links terroristische
organisation verstehen und das ist in
der tat sehr interessant denn doch die
gleiche organisation hat doch auch in
die medien ganz groß geschrieben mit
denen sie ja zusammen arbeiten und im
übrigen im übrigen was auch ganz
interessant wäre eine untersuchung der
verstrickung wie sie alle mit der antifa
nämlich haben das müssen sie sich auch
gefallen lassen
das wissen sie und darum scheint sie
auch so sie können einfach immer nur vor
allem sie von der dinge immer nur
gerufen wenn es um sachliche politik
hilft in die media- die antifa schreibt
dort gaspistolen an die schläfe von
menschen zu setzen um sie zu töten und
mit diesen leuten wollen sie
zusammenarbeiten schämen sie sich da
gibt es überhaupt nichts glatten stellen
das nicht gefallen lassen das ist
furchtbar
während ihr steht mir dann auch noch
dahin trommelt das personal der afg zu
attackieren das weiter denn damit und
sie niederzuschlagen wie dem
bundestagsabgeordneten uwe kammann jetzt
gerade am infostand wollen sie uns
verprügeln was wollen sie denn machen
sie haben schon lange den demokratischen
korridor verlassen auch die spd für
möglich
die hole ist nicht angehalten na gut
straßen ich war ja gerade bei der
infrastruktur das möchte ich gerne zu
ende führen straße und verkehrswege sind
ebenfalls in einem desolaten zustand die
hälfte unserer autobahnbrücken ist weit
über 40 jahre alt und gar nicht für den
schwerlastverkehr der heutigen zeit
ausgelegt ausgeblutet ist im übrigen
auch die bundeswehr flügellahme jets
fahruntaugliche panzer u-boote im
trockendock vom nato ziel 2 prozent in
den wer etat sind wir weit entfernt und
dieses land ist de facto nichts zu
verteidigen mit der bundeswehr die wir
gerade haben wir sind ein land ohne
landesverteidigung und das haben sie
auch zu verantworten und geradezu ein
entwicklungsland ist deutschland in
sachen digitaler infrastruktur
lächerliche das muss man sich mal auf
der zunge zergehen lassen 2,3 prozent
der anschlüsse in deutschland sind
glasfaserleitung der oecd-durchschnitt
liegt bei 22,3 prozent also der
durchschnitt ist zehnmal höher als
hierzulande liter und ist im übrigen mit
71 prozent an europas spitze und uns
meilenweit voraus dem ausbau des
mobilfunknetzes sieht es im übrigen auch
nicht besser aus ja wir reden hier über
den haushalt hier liegt deutschland
nämlich in europa auf platz 32 weit
abgeschlagen hinter albanien besserungen
was die öffentlichen investitionen
angeht sind nicht in sicht und der
bundesfinanzminister plant sie sogar
entgegen seiner gestrigen eigenen
aussage bis 2022 sogar von 37,9
milliarden sogar noch auf 33,5
milliarden zurück zu fahren also es wird
noch weniger investiert ein schwerer
fehler der unserem land noch steuer
teuer zu stehen kommt wird
und zieh dich doch das hauptproblem
ihrer und soliden haushalts- und
finanzpolitik sie leben nur im
augenblick das mag ihn vielleicht ihr
therapeut für ein fröhliches dasein
empfohlen haben
diese haltung taugt aber leider nicht
dazu ein land in die zukunft zu führen
und aus diesem grund ist auch ihre
erzählung von der schwarzen null eben
nur ein märchen um keine tatsächliche
zustandsbeschreibung des
staatshaushaltes für die forderungen
künftiger rentner und pensionäre müssten
rückstellungen in der bilanz wie in
einem jedem unternehmen nämlich
ausgewiesen und eingestellt werden denn
sie sind plötzlich nichts anderes als in
der zukunft liegenden
zahlungsverpflichtungen der kameralistik
eben darum wer das auch nicht
eingestellt
das bittere erwachen kommt schon bald
nämlich dann wenn die geburtenstarken
jahrgänge ihre ansprüche gegen die
rentenkasse eben geltend machen in der
zwischenzeit wird in ihrer renten
kommission herum diskutiert wie der
finanzminister das gestern dargelegt hat
gehandelt wird seit jahrzehnten nicht
obwohl ihm die demografische entwicklung
lange bekannt ist und durch die
ungeregelte zuwanderung von
unqualifizierten auch noch verschärft
wird eine generation bilanzierung nimmt
die bundesregierung ebenfalls nicht vor
rechne man die demografische entwicklung
unseres landes mit 1
dann müssen bis zu 3,8 prozent des bips
zusätzlich gespart werden um für die
künftig an steigenden belastung
vorgesorgt zu haben
und das besagt wohlgemerkt der
tragfähigkeitsbericht des
finanzministeriums zusammenfassend kann
man sagen die merkel-regierung haben
über jahre haushaltspolitisch einen
doppelten fehler begangen zum einen
wurde die tatsächliche verschuldung
immer wieder in die höhe getrieben und
zum anderen durch fehlende investitionen
in die infrastruktur die grundlage für
zukünftige einnahmen drastisch
verschlechtert und als wenn die marode
infrastruktur in unserem land nicht
schon schlimm genug wäre hat frau merkel
auch noch das kunststück zustande
gebracht aus deutschland das land mit
den höchsten strom
reisen in europa zu machen sie sind
nämlich fast doppelt so hoch wie in
frankreich der völlig überstürzen und
doppelten energiewende sei dank die cdu
die cdu hat damit dem mittelstand und im
handwerk denen sie vorgeht zu vertreten
den durch stoß versetzt das sollte ihnen
klar sein
dabei ist es aber an der zeit dem
mittelstand und den geringverdienern
endlich den rücken zu stärken
doch von ihnen kommt dazu nichts
vorschläge warum nicht 2000 euro pro
monat als steuerfreies einkommen
wieso lässt man altersrenten nicht
grundsätzlich steuerfrei warum nicht
runter mit der mehrwertsteuer warum kein
familiensplitting warum nicht weg mit
dem soli und und und davon kommt
überhaupt nichts aber die wohl fatalste
fehlleistung eines regierungschefs
dieser republik erfolgte vor drei jahren
um und um bei der finanzpolitischen
ebene zu bleiben
den deutschen steuerzahler wird allein
das wir schaffen das des herbstes 2015
900 bis 1500 milliarden euro kosten
das ergeben berechnungen des
renommierten ökonom bernd raffelhüschen
obwohl deutsches recht und europäische
regeln gebrochen wurden obwohl das
finanzielle und soziale desaster immer
stärker zutage tritt gestehen sie liebe
frau bundeskanzlerin keinen fehler ein
ganz im gegenteil unrecht soll zurecht
umgemünzt werden stichwort globaler
migrations packt und unter dem
schlagwort spurwechsel will die
regierung auch noch ausreisepflichtigen
migranten ein bleiberecht erteilen
die millionen die in afrika bereits auf
ihren gepackten koffern sitzen werden
dass als zusätzliche ermunterung und
einladung verstehen doch sie wollen die
aktion auch noch allen ernstes mit dem
kraft fachkräftemangel verteidigen und
es ist wirklich nicht zu fassen
es ist aufgabe mit einer jeden ja sie
haben eben eine wohlig gestoppt also
darum
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen sie haben
die uhr weiterlaufen lassen nachher hat
sie noch in der antwort war also nach
dem was sich auf geführt habe so ist das
wenn man zwischen fragen zulässt
plötzlich läuft die uhr weiter man kommt
nicht mehr hinnehmen sie also endlich
das zepter des handelns in die hand
handeln sie zum wohle unseres landes
deutschland alles weitere
fraktionsvorsitz
die drei der zumindest phasenweise von
persönlichen angriffen geprägt war und
man könnte durchaus den eindruck
gewinnen auch einige offensichtlich
absichtlich in falsche interpretationen
einige zitate